"25 Guys who used their Photoshop skills to get hot Girlfriends"
That sounds pretty impressive to me
Isn't it Ains-
*RIP  /╲/\╭( ͡° ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° ͡°)╮/\╱\ Ainsley*
Anyway...let's- Let's check it out!
Oh I see...
It's one of those...where they make fun
They make fun of- of-of-of guys for having Anime girlfriends! (yep)
I find this very offensive. (who cares)
You don't know their story!
You don't know their past!
You don't know their History!
You don't know SHIT! (yes i do you know, i read the all and mighty bib-ble)
OK?
Fuck you for laughing at this!
OK?!
Love just like Genders come in very different shapes and colors (queer)
"Wer- Yes! We're in love. We don't care who sees."
Thats god damn right!
*patriotic poods*
And I want this stigma
AGAINST ANIME LOVING GIRLFRIENDS, TO GO AWAY!!!
If Joe Bidon(Joe Biden ffs poods) does it...it's ok?!
OH I see...
(you can't see him) If John Cena has an Animu Girlfriend *inhales* then its ok?!?!
Having celebrities come out...admitting that they love their anime wife...(waifu)
Can really help bring out the-the anime wife community forward
Putin can have anime babes...
So to break this horrible...disgusting stigma... I'm going to Photoshop...Youtubers with anime Girlfriends
To hopefully do some positive impact with my voice on this platform (you damn nazi)
53 million... i hope we can finally... make a difference (54 mil now poods)
I mean so this can go from "LOL" to "Love"
*from lol to love* <3 by pewds
What anime girlfriend do I think would fit Jack? *heh*
I think Jack would fit quite nicely with some- the silent...*break*...errrr the silent type. *lol cuz jack is always loud xD*
You know to sorta compensate
*inhales*
Yuki Nagatho
*happy music*
*chuckles*
*more happy music*
This is really the fun part of Photoshop doing the pencil tool I love it so much... It's always so refreshing and fulfilling...
It is so fun to see how he follows the lines of ~jackspedicey's~ cheeks
so nice, very nice..
****Music****
[slightly chuckle's]
Alright, we got one side finished
[laughing]  "It's so beautiful"
let's uh, let's move her a little closer
They're such a- they're such a cute couple
Hell yeah! Waifu 4 laifu! *pewds laughs*
I've always suspected
and I - I think we all know
deep down
that Keemstar ...
is the biggest anime fan on the planet
That's why I'm not gonna photoshop Keemstar
I'm gonna photoshop Scarce
The only motions
behind those glasses
are FEAR
and screaming
HELP ME
I would rather be... with a real... girlfriend
I'm here
I'm here for you Scarce!
Ok?
I care about you.
Despite what you may think. I care
Why do I do what I do?
Cause I'm a god damn hero
*♫The Greatest America Hero - Joey Scarbury♫*
Three girls
A red head, a blond, and a brunette
*Walked into a bar...?*
Surely there must be an anime for *mutters*
YES
I think I found
your anime girlfriend... Scarce
*♫The Greatest America Hero - Joey Scarbury♫*
*Believe it or not*
*♫I'M walking on air. I never thought I could feel so free-ee-ee!♫*
*This is what Skavlan was talking about Pewds*
Scarce I'm gonna hit you up with something way better...
Some Love Live! girls
Ahh... we got
H-Haki Nishikino
*It's Maki, pewds*
We got... Hanayo Koizumi
And of course... Ha... the blond...
My personal favourite
you're welcome
Erri Ayase
*music plays*
Alright, we got one girlfriend.
We got two girlfriends.
We got three girlfriends.
Scarce, you're a lucky man.
You're a lucky son of a-
Why am I doing this. I dont-
Disgusting,
drinking,
naked,
foul women.
ahhh
Hot anime babes having a great time
with Scarce in the Vegas.
I applaud you Scarce,
I applaud you for coming out publicly
to show how much you love anime.
From- From one anime
man to another.
[typing sound]
JohnScarce #expose
it was photoshopped all along...
*music playing*
This is a beautiful thing.
This is a thing worth celebrating.
I think we have time
for one more.
Jacksepticeye replied " Oh yeah dude, we go WAY back!
Love me some Yuki ~~ugu~~ ^_^"
I think we've all suspected.
But if there's one- was one person
so influential
that is love for anime
could change
the planet.
Yes!
This is the perfect image.
Who should we put there?
Himouto! Umaru-chan.
I'm a little jealous but I- [laughing]
I really think-
I really ship them, I really do.
I really ship quite a lot.
Damn!
Okay. Whoa.
Jesus
Truuuump
He likes to hump
I don't know what rimes with "hump"
anime babes
ALL NIGHT LONG
He really didn't wanna be president
He really just wanna to stay home and watch anime
Wich I can do later.
Do you think I wanna be here?
He wants to hump anime babes.
All night long.
ANIME BABES
[laughing]
YEEES!
I'm proud of you trump!
Finally,
you did something worth [applaud] celebrating.
I applaud to you Trump,
I applaud you.
Lot of people couldn't get a girl like that.
Lot of people don't know.
Alright, so that was aahhhh
Anime video...
Anyway-
wait.
What is this?
Marzia?
Ainsley
How could this be? No.
No!
How?
He must not go back in time...
Resurrected himself
Stole my GF.. My real life Girlfriend!!
No..
No! This can't be happening..
Marzia.. :(